en retour en france avec l'ouverture à
paris du procès de l'assassinât du père
hamel a tué il ya six ans à coups de
couteau en pleine messe dans son église
de saint-etienne du rouvray en normandie
si les djihadistes ont été tués par la
police trois membres de l'entourage des
assaillants sont dans le box aujourd'hui
entre tout de suite 4 pique nique sur
place
katia que faut-il attendre de ce premier
jour de procès
j'ai tout simplement de découvrir des
personnes qui auraient pu aider ou
encourager les deux tueurs à passer à
l'acte comme vous le disiez il doit
trois personnes dans le box il en manque
une quatrième l'instigateur présumé
rachid kaci qui lui aurait été jugé pour
complicité car il aurait incité au
passage à l'acte et ils seraient morts
dans un bombardement en irak en 2017 il
reste donc trois hommes jean philippe
jean louis farid quelle île et yasin c
bahia qui sont jugés pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes des hommes
décrits comme radicaux et qui aurait été
au courant du funeste projet alors
aujourd'hui il y à égal ce procès très
évidemment un but très poignant il y à
la soeur du père hamel rose line hamel
ainsi que geek au poney qui étaient
présents lors de cette messe qui a été
grièvement blessé et puis finalement
aujourd'hui il se dit dans une mission
spirituelle vous propose d'écouter
rosina mail ainsi que guy koponen
que la justice soit faite on est tous là
pour ça alors fait passer maintenant
pour régler les derniers problèmes qu'il
ya quelque chose qui soit bon pour tout
le monde s'il ya beaucoup de malheurs
qu'il en est j'en ai conclu de ces
événements alors bon que ceux qui sont
responsables
ben s'ils peuvent vous demander pardon
à tous ceux à qui ils ont fait de la
peine je pense qu'on harraga arts a
gagné d'autres journées
ces jeunes qui
et participez au moyen de
tu es mon frère
sont des victimes
eux aussi
du terrorisme
cet attentat aurait pu être évitée si
les recherches des liens qui ont été
trouvés après l'attentât aurait été
profondément
rechercher
les raisons pour lesquelles
ça n'a pas été pris au sérieux les
annonces
c'est presque
inaudible pour nous
des questions seront aussi posé sur la
surveillance des criminels puisque l'un
d'eux était porteur d'un bracelet
électronique à cause d'une tentative de
départ en syrie et première surprise
aujourd'hui quatre agents de la
direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police de paris avait été
appelé à témoigner à la demande des
parties civiles en effet certains
avaient intercepté des communications
d'un des deux auteurs dans lesquelles il
disait qu'il souhaitait éliminer une
personne un homme d'église mais ces
informations n'avaient pas été traités
par la hiérarchie alors où est le
dysfonctionnement eh bien surprise
aujourd'hui comme je vous le disais
puisque les quatre agents son possesseur
d'une dispense médicale soit pour
raisons psychologiques ou de santé ils
se disent brisé par cette affaire
mettant en cause leur probité les
avocats des parties civiles se sont
indignées en expliquant que les parties
civiles elle est bien le faisait face et
elle dominé leurs émotions malgré le
massacre et donc les avocats sont
surpris par à ces certificats selon eux
cela ressemble à une dérobade qui
renforce les suspicions
alors qu'une information connue aurait
pu éviter les attentats à l'époque les
révélations avaient été faites par
mediapart
merci katia technique pour toutes ces
précisions merci également à ma cisma
dayraut qui vous accompagnent derrière
la caméra